The joe rogan experience.
If you're going to,
I've never told this story and I haven't told the story because it's a scary
one.
Um,
I've never told this story before,
but I'm going to tell you,
you don't know the story of Joe.
Um,
last summer I went to south of France and I was with my wife and my buddy and
he,
the first day were there.
He goes,
we're going to go cliff diving.
And I said,
hmm,
I don't like that idea.
Okay.
It's a group of people.
One guy's the best horseback rider in the world,
whatever random stuff.
So we get there and do,
we get there and we're up there and it's,
it's,
it's the ocean number one.
Number two,
it's craggy rocks.
Number three,
it's very high.
And number four,
it's cold.
So I look over and my instincts and I go,
so if we jump,
where are we supposed to swim too?
And the surfer,
who was from there,
I said over there,
but I don't like the way the tide is washing up on those rocks.
So I go,
hmm,
that's all I had to here.
Not going to do it.
Prosing cons,
not going to do it.
The horseback rider jumps his,
his chubby girl jumps and guess who else jumps?
My wife,
mother of my children,
she just goes,
she's talked about it,
but she's like,
I'm doing this to competitive chick.
She goes,
oh,
that girl's going to do it.
I'm doing it.
So that's my,
that's the mother of my children.
So guess what?
I got to go in and make sure she's okay.
So I jumped in and you're scared shitless.
I wasn't scared about jumping.
I was mad.
I was mad because I don't like the ocean.
I was mad because I didn't have a good instinct about it.
I was mad because I don't know that area.
And the mother and children decides to,
doesn't really mad about they see your,
I said,
fuck these kids.
I'm going to jump into this.
Rochelle.
My wife is brutally competitive and she's not going to let somebody won.
So,
so what?
Right.
That's ridiculous.
Now I jump in and I know you and I are the same mind because your cost is like
this too.
I jump in and I,
I swim,
we swim and now we have to go up on the rocks and the waves are hitting these
rocks.
So I said to Amanda,
I go,
we're going to have to ride this wave onto these rocks.
Let me go first so I can turn around and pick,
grab you.
No big deal.
I go and as I go and turn around,
I get hit with a second wave with which just came out of nowhere.
It,
it,
it literally knocks me,
rolls me on this really sharp coral.
So my feet,
my hands,
everything's all full of blood.
My waist,
my waist,
legs are all full of blood.
She starts to kind of panic.
She goes and like that and the ways and stuff.
Cause I got the wind knocked out of me and I'm telling you right now,
I,
I grabbed her and she goes,
get away from me.
She thought I was going to drown her so I have to [inaudible] well she just
didn't want it.
She didn't tell.
She thought I was gonna bring her down.
So just so I have to calm her down.
So it gets so bad cause I can't grab her.
I tried to get her back up on the rocks again.
Washed off again.
Okay,
so now,
now I'm swollen with seawater.
She's swollen seawater and,
and,
and I'm literally,
I'm literally talking to me like this,
like go.
All right,
no big deal.
We're just going to,
we're not going to stay here.
Let's relax.
Let's just swim further out so we can get used to these waves.
Let's wait until it calms down.
It's crisis mode,
crisis.
It's crisis mode.
And I realize that I'm panicked and I don't really actually have the strength.
I'm worried that I'm going to go,
I'm trying to,
I got to hold her up because she's,
she's strong and I think,
and I,
and I think I've got to get behind her,
but she's literally pushing me away.
Now she grabs onto me and now I'm like,
oh boy,
I gotta I gotta get it together here because she's holding onto me and kind of
pulling me under the dude who's the surfer sees what's going on.
He dives in,
he grabs her.
I literally,
I'm holding her.
He comes up and I go take her,
take her like really calm.
I go take her cause she's panicking.
He grabs her,
he ends up having to put her on top of him and he lets the wave ride them up.
He gets his whole back and legs ripped up and he pulls her on shore.
So she's a bloody mess.
I ride the next wave in my feet,
my hands,
my body.
I'm all ripped up.
I'm all ripped up for the rest of the v.
The vacation never been more angry so bad by the way,
that the helicopter that the rescue helicopter shows up and and people all
crowded around like where they saw everything happened.
Then I'm full of blood and we're all full of blood.
The rescue helicopter comes up,
which is by the way,
some $20,000 fine or something.
We,
I grab Amanda,
I grab my,
grab my friends,
I go,
let's get in the car.
Now they're going to equate the,
they think of the catches and figure out it's us.
So we jumped in the car and drive off.
That was the scariest I,
what I realized there was that the sea can take you so quickly,
you just go to the bottom.
Then I find them,
you will see you later love.
And that should happens all the time because people are,
if you don't know how to ride,
you know,
currents and waves,
if you're not used to it,
if you know a good swimmer,
swimmer,
lose your life.
Yeah,
and I am a good swimmer.
You know what I thought about?
You know what's crazy to me,
into your family.
Think about me.
I thought about my kids getting without their mom.
I wasn't going back without,
without their mom.
I wasn't going to happen.
And that's way scarier than me losing my life.
I never had that expression.
If you didn't jump in,
well that's exactly.
Imagine if you didn't.
Exactly.
That's why they should suffer.
But it sounds like there was a lot of space between a lot for jumping in and a
surfer and the surfer in,
Oh my God,
he didn't know we were in trouble.
Oh my God.
That's why I jumped in.
And that's why you see the big fight after,
you know,
it was so scary.
That was thankful.
She was,
uh,
she was okay.
Whew.
That was a bad situation.
I don't even like telling a story cause it was cause,
cause of the feeling it gave me like I didn't feel you.
It's not good to feel that vulnerable to see is a scary bitch.
The scheme.
I don't fuck around.
I love the ocean.
My buddy who says something that's not fun.
My buddy used to have to take,
uh,
he would,
he would make his money by sailing boats in the winter for rich people up the
Atlantic,
which doubled during storm season sailboats.
And he was only one of the few people willing to do that.
And ice,
he got caught in a storm for 23 hours or the swells were going over his body.
They couldn't,
they had to literally fly a guy from Alaska in a special boat cause nobody else
could do it,
could navigate the storm who tugged him in and he strapped himself and he was
getting hypothermia as the water and he couldn't see the waves at night.
He had to wait to hear them because they would just come over the boat and the
whole boat would submerge.
Oh,
that happened.
That happened for him.
That happened for about 10 hours.
Just kept some merging and they were out.
He keeps [inaudible] from cap and you've got to steer you towards the weight.
You've got to be an expert.
And he was so,
so,
uh,
they were stuck out there and you're at the mercy of the C and a lot of times
you just get washed up on rocks and you die.
So we had to keep the rocks.
He got to keep away from the rocks and he had to keep the boat.
He had to deal with these insane waves at night where you can't see them.
Nature's another love rocks and the water and the water got a simultaneously
worry about bolts.
Sounds right.
And you're in a metal boat for 10 hours.
It's a wood boat.
It's a word blood.
Yeah.
It's a wood boat.
It's a sailboat.
Oh,
a sale.
You can keep that shit keyed that ocean shit.
And I said to him,
I said,
do you ever,
what kind of a,
would you have a life vest?
He goes,
you don't wear a life vest.
I Wa I.
What do you mean?
He goes,
you look,
if you get knocked over,
you're dying.
You guys,
and and chances are life that is going to keep you cold and alive longer than
you want to be.
You're not even,
they can,
they can't come back and find you because they can't get you out back on the
boat.
They camp in that kind of weather.
You're probably injured anyway.
Now those guys are hardcore.
Keep it,
keep being humbled.
That fucking deadliest catch show you ever watched that show?
Those guys are up there just catching it tracks how much don't delicious could
crabs be because somebody decided that this is what they wanted to do with their
time.
If you fall in that water,
you got about two minutes before you have for your dead hypothermia.
Yeah.